في تونس كارثه بيئيه وصحيه اذا حذرت نقابه
الاطباء بصفاقس جنوبيه شرقي البلاد من
خطوره وضع وبقي شراء ازمه النفايات
المستمره منذ اكثر من عام ينضم الينا من
صفاقس وليد عبد الله مراسل العربيه وليد
كيف هي الصوره من هناك ومن هي الجهه التي
تتحمل المسؤوليات مع ما الذي يحصل هناك
اليوم
مساء الخير ميسون نحن الان في وسط مدينه
صفاقس تحديدا امام مقر بلديه
المكان هنا انتظمت منذ قليل وقفه احتجاجيه
هي الثانيه في اليوم ذاته من قبل المنظمات
المجتمع المدني للتعبير عن الغضب والاسيه
والاحتجاج على تراكم النفايات ثم حرق مكب
النفايات في طريق البناء وتعاطي السلطات
على مستوى المحلي الجهوي وايضا حتى على
المستوى الوطني لمعتذر من قبل لمنظمات
المجتمع واهالي صفاقس كارثه بيئيه وجريمه
ارهابيه في حق همم بعد مسيره انتظمت صباح
اليوم نظامها الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
لتعبير عن الغضب ولحف السلطات على القيام
دي تدخل لايجاد حلول عاجله لهذه الكارثه
الصحيه وال- همم البيئيه وربما ايضا
المرور الى حلول على المدى المتوسط
مع النفايات عبر تسمينها ربما في انتظار
تحركه اخرى تصعيديه ان لم يتم التجاوب على
كل من يتحمل المسؤوليه وحتى نفهم اكثر
ينضم الينا السيد منير اللومي رئيس بلديه
صفقه سيد منير اهلا وسهلا بك انت معنا على
المباشر على شاشه العربيه ازمه حقيقيه
بيئيه اعتبرت جريمه ارهابيه من قبل
المنظمات المجتمع على المدني عام وشهرين
لماذا هذا تاخر في الطاعاتي مع هذه الازمه
شكرا همم الازمه انطلقت بالحق يوم 27
سبتمبر 20 21 لما وقع الغلق الفوشئي لمصب
الجنه بمنطقه عقارب وهو المصب الوحيد
المراقب اللي كان على ذمه كل البلديات
الولايه لنقل النفايات همم الغلق هدايا ما
خلانيش امكانيه انه همم نحضره الواحد انه
يكونوا عنا همم
بديله وهذاك اللي خلقنا الازمه خلينا نشوف
الحلول الحلول ما كانتش ممكن لانه همم
اكثر شيء
عطلنا هو عدم المقبولين الاجتماعيه اللي
همم كانت همم كل المناطق تقريبا ماذا نقصد
بالمقبوليه المجتمعيه من يتحمل هذا كل
المناطق اللي نحبهم همم نخلطوا فيها مسبات
جديده ترفض انه
يقع النقل كم كل الكميات الموجوده في
المدينه وفي منطقه صفاقس الكبرى الى
هممم وهدايا اللي يعطل همم
[موسيقى]
ايجاد الحدود ولكن كذلك همم قلنا احنا في
استراتيجياتنا وفي همم الحديث عن
استراتيجيات رئيس الجمهوريه البارحه
يستقبل وزيره البيئه ويتحدث عن من يعطل
رفع هذه الفضلات من يعطل وانت من البلديات
المسؤولون رقم واحد عند رفع هذه النفايات
من عدت العمل لكم احنا همم همم لان كل
المعدات وكل التجهيزات وكل همم
مع الاعوان المكلفين برفع النفايات على
اتم الاستعداد ل همم رفع هذه الكميه
المهوله لاصبحت في كامل الارجاء المدينه
ولكن الامكنه المعدل لذلك هي اللي
افتقدناها لمده طويله وخليت تراكم الفضلات
في كم الارجاء المدينه هو اللي همم بالحق
همم اصبح يمثل عبء كبير على همم المدينه
وفيها
الخطوره اللي قاعدين نعيشوا فيها خطوره
اصبحت صحيه اضافه الى همم الحريق الكبير
للدراع في المصب ال- همم اللي هو بيده همم
فتحناه لمده قصيره حتى يعني نحتويه
والازمه همم منذ السنه الفرده ولكن المده
هديه وهو كيف يتحمل المسؤوليه هذه المده
سنه
همم شهرين هل تنقصكم او تعوزكم الامكانيات
هل الرفض المجتمع هو فقط من ادى الى هذه
الكارثه ماذا سيد منير
المشكل هو في ايجاد الحلول
الدائمه
مع انت في انجاز وحدات التسمين اللي قلنا
لا بد من الخروج من منظومه الردم الى
منظومه التسمين هذه الحب لها امكانيه
كبيره تحبلها بانتظار ذلك في حسنا الوقت
ربما ما هو الحل العاجل والاكيد والفوري
الان همم تعاطي مع هذه الكارثه البيئيه
والصحيه الحل العاجل هو الان هو اطفاء
الحريق الموجود في طريق الميناء حتى نتجنب
بالكارثه الصحيه يمكن تحلب المدينه هذا
اولا ثانيا احنا قاعدين نقوم برفع الكميات
الموجوده قاعدين نهزوا في اماكن همم
ولكن لابد من اجل كان
مهيا على الاقل
ليه قبول هذه الوقت شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
منير رئيس سعودي اليك شكرا لك